ashin one prepare thyself for dark souls
3 DLC I'm Lucy and welcome to your game
spot news update time for rolling ashes
of aerion dell will launch on october
twenty fifth of a ps4 xbox one and pc
the expansion will give players the
opportunity to travel to a brand new
area to uncover a terrible secret but of
course in standard souls fashion the
DLCs plot isn't explicitly revealed all
we know is that players will journey
into the frozen land of re Andale where
they'll have to defeat the evil within
and uncover the mystery of what
destroyed the region you'll probably
take on some new bosses and get killed a
bunch of times in the process too
according to publisher Bandai Namco
players will find themselves steeped in
a brand new environment filled with
terrifying new enemies challenges and
exciting law to expand the overarching
Dark Souls 3 storyline screenshots for
the DLC have been released alongside a
brand new trailer and interestingly
there seem to be a number of allusions
to the first Dark Souls painted world of
re amis in them on top of being a snowy
environment like the painted world re
Andale will have an enemy similar to the
crow demon there's also concept art for
an NPC character called painter
Priscilla the part dragon crossbreed
that ruled over the painted world wasn't
featured in Dark Souls 3 but her lineage
is represented in the game fans have
speculated that she may be connected to
a character called yashka who looks
strikingly similar to priscilla ashes of
aerion dell could explore this
connection but of course this is all
speculation on our part the ashes of re
andale expansion will also include new
weapons armor sets and magic for players
to discover and experiment with ashes of
re handle is the first of two dlc
expansions plan for dark souls 3 it
costs fifteen dollars on playstation 4
xbox one and pc the second expansion is
expected in early 2017 so are you ready
for the DLC which ending of the main
game did you get let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I met Lucy James games for more
on Dark Souls 3 make sure you keep it
games for
you